so are you ready to hit the stage as
co-host i'm ready i'm ready man anthony
went golfing yesterday to get a little
more chemistry together
what yeah becoming best friends now at
least i think we are oh yeah how'd you
play are you going to the masters next
year i think so no no no no i didn't
play bad though i played better than i
ever played before well
maybe this is a good sign
oh god and i gotta say you're looking
mighty sharp here thank you i can't take
credit for it i don't know i know but is
this one of how many outfits i think
four
hopefully two
i mean i have four though is the other
outfit a pair of pajamas no no you know
me though i would that's that's me i
always show up in that
co-host performer nominee
what are you excited about hitting that
stage tonight i think i'm just excited
for the the show there's a lot of jokes
i'm really excited about it's cool to
anthony's here it's cool that kelsey
gets to still be a part of this
the music that you're performing your
music your performance well yeah i don't
talk about myself but i'm going to talk
about you who are you what are you
performing for the fans this is a fan
voted award show so that's i'm really
excited about that and you're a big fan
of your lovely wife back here aren't you
she's talking to jordan davis i mean
jordan davis yeah why don't we just get
the gang in here what did you think when
you got the call or when cain got the
call to fill in for kelsey in the flesh
here for the awards oh i thought it was
incredible i'm like super excited for
kane to do this yeah so it's unfortunate
for kelsey i know hoping her the best
but it was really cool we were we were
out of state so i was like we gotta go
to your parents house right yeah oh my
gosh unbelievable and congratulations on
baby number two
thank you she's the best she's such a
great baby well that was quite the
secret young lady yes it was uh hard
after i hit seven months we were like it
was a lot of this
yeah
yeah good thank goodness for zooms right
that zoom life health why did you up to
go that route and keep it a secret um i
just wanted the privacy you know social
media can be a little harsh and people
telling you what to do all the time and
i just wanted to cherish that moment
with just me and kane and and i loved
every second of it i would do it again
i cannot get enough of y'all's videos
with kingsley i mean
she is just she thinks daddy's the best
thing since sliced bread huh that's just
the videos i show you she loves mama too
yeah